wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder alles neu beginnt
wir sehen hier in hamburg ist ziemlich
windig und kalt die erst 19 uhr morgens
wir fahren hier auf der elbe in hamburg
und das kann das tun aber wir sehen hier
auf der master clip polizei und los
geht's
servus wohin wir fahren jetzt eine kurze
streifen durch den hamburger rasen zu
einmal den container terminal
altenwerder dass wir einen riesen
vertrügen den schutz von ca 350 meter
länge 45 meter breite und der kann bis
zu 10.000 containern transportieren
was ist denn da vorne da wo diese blue
chip ist hier ist eine der bekanntesten
werken in hamburg
ein werk das immer dafür vereinbart zu
reparieren oder eben um schiffe
entsprechend zu bauen also wie eine
autowerkstatt
die auf der elbe auch piraten wir hatten
hier mal vor kurzer zeit das war eine
separatistenbewegung abert hatte und
dann ist die wasserschutz immer an bord
gegangen oder so aufgeklärt
wir wollten auf und hat sich also nichts
mehr wir haben eigentlich mit schiffer
polizeilichen aufgaben zur schule das
heißt kontrolle von schiffen
kontrollieren die pässe wären wir jetzt
gerade einen dicken baumstämmen hier im
wasser treiben den kurs erstmal an ob
denn nicht gefährlich für die kleinstadt
werden könnte
sonst müssen wir veranlassen dass der
weg gewollt wird also mit planet er ganz
schön und werden auch viel gesehen aber
jetzt habe ich echt mal lust selber zu
fahren
dafür müssen wir erst ein alkoholtest
machen
das leasing behörden fahrzeug danke 0,0
promille kann nichts passieren
backbord links steuern zu rechts in
fahrtrichtung was ist das
nach vorne ist gas geben
also ich bin ja einiges geworden aber so
langsam merke ich schon
seekrank übernehme ich mal wieder den
coolen tag mit dem jüngst von der
wasserschutzpolizei
wir haben super netter ich kann mich den
runde war vielen dank und wenn meine
antwort war viel zu zaghaft